i don't know if you want to stay on it
but
i think that was book number one or two
[ __ ] yeah okay all right all right um
is there well this one is a second this
actually is a corollary to that which is
sapiens and i know that's a very normal
normy answer yeah um one of the best
selling but i think there's a reason for
that yeah
you've all know harari of course okay
look yes he didn't do any new research
i get that all he did was aggregate i'm
sure he's very controversial in the
scientific community
but guess what he wrote a great book
it's a very
easy to read general explanation of the
rise of human
history and it helps challenge a lot of
preconceptions are we special
are we an accident are we more like a
parasite or are we not
what is there a destiny to all of us i
don't know
you know if anything it's like what i
just described which is more
move move out um the evolution of money
like i know he gets a lot of hate but i
think that he writes it
so clearly and well that for your
average person to be able to read that
you will come away
with a more clear understanding of the
human race
than before and i think that that's why
it's worth it i agree with you 100
i uh i'm ashamed to i usually don't
bring up sapiens because it's like
yeah it's like everybody's uncle has
read it but it's that's a good thing
yeah it is one of the i think it'll be
remembered as one of the great books of
this particular era
and yeah because it's it's so clearly
it's like the
selfish gene with doc is i mean it just
aggregates so many ideas together and
puts language to it that's
makes it very useful to talk about so it
is one of the great books
you